Erosion, at fact, in some sense,
is easier to even think about.
Again, I have a binary image B.
And I've got a structuring element,
okay?
And now, my structuring element is this
little tall column here of just ones,
and its origin is in the middle.
And the way erosion works is,
I take my structuring element, and
I run it over a picture.
I, and, and what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to take the AND of the ones i,
in my structuring element with the,
with the pixels below it in the image.
And I take the AND.
Well that means that all of them
have to be a 1 for it to be a 1.
So another way of saying this is,
when I put my structuring element down,
all of its 1s that are touched
1s in the underlying image, or
I'm going to set the value to a 0.
So before we take a look at what the
result is, let's think about where can
you put this thing down in this picture,
such that it touches only 1s.
And you realize, well, I could put
it here with my origin there, right?
I could put it here,
with my origin there, and
the same thing over to this column.
And that's the only place, and
that's why the result of
this is this right there.
And by the way,
I guess I didn't mention the other one,
this circle with a minus on it,
that's referred to as erosion and
the circle with a plus,
that's the dilation nomenclature, okay?